jetzt schalter und aber ich bin in die
andere richtung gefahren
ich kann einfach nicht lassen das
verstehe ich das so ja nein was soll da
ist schon wieder in die an dicht an
dicht durch wissen du wissen wieder
hochgekommen einfach ganz normal
es soll kaka bis gesprungen oder wie ein
opa typisch andy
höher
da ich sehen einen haben sie auch den
namen zum pennen gehn als 20.000 m
okay was du kannst ihn wo der salami
martinus einer frau fischer ich habe
eigentlich vorgenommen ich runter zu
schützen aber dann habe ich mich
nein man n a
es muss das ganz schnell schaffen
nein kurzform sicherheit nicht machbar
wahrscheinlich schon
hey response
ist das denn die kirche kaka gut ich bin
durch oder was fast
ich sehe dich
wie soll ich das schaffen jump ja wohin
welcher war hoch springen
nee ist ja nix ich weiß nicht ich jetzt
eine lava springen ja wow
das hat's gebracht auf jeden fall jetzt
kriegt ihr vertrauen
jakub dahinter steckt die job und ich
weiß nicht wohin man wo hast du drauf
geschlagen
meine beine ach man das hat sie
ergatterte so aus macbook als puffer
wenn man ich war grad unter der lava
gestorben bin und da habe ich gesehen
dass da unten irgendwie sondern und
komische frau war
nein
das schafft er den stift oder und fertig
dafür werde ich sorgen nur auch man das
ist alles kacke
o
auf solche talente alter wenn ihm schon
20 minuten auf du bist du wohl immer die
hilfen
ich dachte dass gestorben
man weiß was wir bringen uns selber voll
viel weiter dem uns mehr unterschlagen
ja so ich bin ok das dorf
irgendwas einfaches machen können aber
nein der herr luca möchte hier
das ist auch so ein bisschen challenges
sein als meine bisher zum beispiel ist
es ja nicht nur spring ich meine vorhin
weinkarte ist weil der relativ einfach
mal wo ich bin ja da war auch schon das
ist jetzt relativ einfach alles habe ich
weiß nicht wie es weitergeht nein
ja ich würde ihnen die mal runter
springen den lava oder so ob es denn du
grad gesprungen ungefähr einfach stumpf
geradeaus mit schwimmt aber gegen die
wand vor sie und das ging nicht einfach
so eine leiter runter das ganze mit all
ihren gott nein und kann ich das nicht
wenn du es schaffst viele ganz luca
elegant
overmann grad sieht man bestimmt wieder
deinen sich noch grassiert nach so viel
schnee den gesuchten machen muss aber
egal ist ja nicht so dass ich etwas
anderes zu tun hat oder so ich fange
gerade nach 1 übrigens kennen martin und
durch kunst aus wie man automatisch ist
keiner so von youtube lassen ein
bisschen was über mich erzählen
also ich bin 23
nein ich bin 17 jahre alt war
nein ja also ich bin 17 komme aus berlin
kreuzberg
ja hab ich gehört dass antworten du bist
du hast und professionell ist
du kannst dein handy auch einmal während
der aufnahme abwarten meinte sie ich bin
fertig mit offenem wasser eiskalt noch
auf online der welt hätte jemand
angesehen werden
wir kommen ja und arschloch
ich will aber nichts sagen jetzt mal
deine videos ist eine der vielen
abwägungs phase ich habe schon wieder
bisher war sein
respawn der dierig geschafft ich krieg
dich jetzt wissen schon selber mut
jetzt konzentriere ich mich da immer
schaden ich weiß nicht wieso
man wusste da schlagen auf den boden
vibrierte sammelte eine
ja ich hab's geschafft als ob doch aber
ich bin noch nicht welche reiter ich
weiß nicht ich bleibe fest nein
okay an die leiter muss man auf jeden
fall ist man nicht runter ja danke bitte
sehr nett von dir manometer muss man da
hinten runter steht jump ich bin ja
gesamt ich meine wir müssen ja
eigentlich nur den leser finden und halt
ne kiste war essen drin ist
ich bin schon wieder hinten guck mal
martin kann man hier kurz auf meinem
bildschirm ich bin jetzt hier vor
solchen springen einfach stumpf gegen
das schild ja du da unten war ich ja
vorhin schon da
im spiel passiert nichts
bei youtube gucken ein dass es blöd vor
allem benutzt damit auf nein
scheiße nimmst du denn überhaupt noch
auf ja seit 23 minuten und 56 jahren ja
ich habe den ausgaben aber ich weiß wie
der ausgang ist aber ich bin dabei
verbrannt weil ich erst woanders war ich
weiß wo er ist
du wirst mich doch verarschen ich will
dich taschen ich hatte gerade so die
phase dachte ich mir jetzt schaffst du
das martin glaub an dich
ich lag da die ganze zeit nichts
passiert ist im creative pool hatten die
sich dennoch nicht schlagen wie spot
sie halten ein münchen nach scheiße
scheiße scheiße laptop im laptop
ich drück doppelt weh und der dicke ganz
normal da solange chip ein schild 1
jetzt stellt sich einige fahrer schon
wieder her das kann doch nicht sein
ich drück doppelbett entschied sich hier
ein die presse ist da hat er wirklich
geworfen als einem scheiß laptop als
billig aber ich bin so behindert ach nee
ich wollte anlauf nehmen wir zur pause
zurück zeigt vom blog runter denn so im
blog
hey das kann ich zeit später bei diesem
sprung aber ich weiß man wenigstens
einmal den ausgang
er ist er nicht der lok direkt dabei dem
schild also bei der wand sondern der
davor links oder rechts neben dem ach so
und ich glaube ich hab's jetzt
alter kuba wo ich bin ich wünsche bei
wasserbecken
ich wünsche dem wasserbecken aber guck
mal ich brenne und bin im wasser gucken
nein wir sitzen mit einer kompletten
folge jetzt daran ich meine zwölf
minuten haben wir so lange gebraucht um
den ausgang zu finden
also gerade meinen tisch geschlagen
wenn ich habe auch meine beine gestellt
die sind halt ein wenig rostig rostig
merke ich immer beim sportklub fängt an
schlaufen zusammen sport haben mein gott
wir haben nur in der gleichen halle in
verschiedenen teilen ja aber selbst
davon dass dann beim laufen
ja ich hab's nicht mal ich habe die
ersten drei sprünge und dann fragt
addieren
ich hoffe jetzt ich hab's geschafft
der schalter gedrückt und ich habe
melonen alte die vier interessanten und
wie komme ich jetzt zurück wer dich
töten
das baulich aber bei den wetten
wie komme ich zurück versetzt hatte ich
kann mich da trinkt dann erst im weg
aber bei äpfeln kann dies alles ist
gleich mitnehmen
ich schaffe ich das ja bitte hier ist
mein körper mitmacht kann kann ich das
kann man vom einkauf stars geschafft
er schaffe es nicht einfach die kleine
kiste sind ein paar sachen essen kann
ich dir gleich geben
das ist stefan gesteht und hdf rate ich
schmeiße auf dem gipfel den sack für den
aufnehmen kannst musst nie ein apfel
kommt gleich apfel aufgenommen ja ja die
ganze zeit dingsbums fledermäuse
soll ich habe andere sachen gegeben ich
würde mich nicht hin ich mache ich schon
nicht nein wirklich nicht
die ganzen main cups braucht man auch
nicht was machst du
martin ich mache gar nix hey das sind
hier prepress up let's help wo bist du
ich bin hinter dir ich hab gar nicht
gesehen dass die bäume warst scheiße ich
war wirklich verbrennen richtig mbh ist
gut ich boxe die 200 wird spielt hier
ein m5 was ich will das jetzt wieder
einfach
numero uno ist tot
david krejci multicar noch kein titel
multicar de castries exekutive das von
immer wieder neuen fall sybille
getroffen ich habe auch in der nase